Dustin is with us in California hi
Dustin welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
how's it going Dave better than I
deserved man what's up in your life well
you know I kind of messed up quite a bit
so I graduated college a year ago from
Chico State and I got a job in San
Francisco and it totally got me in a lot
more debt than I already was so now I
moved to Sacramento I'm trying to you
know pay it all off I already put $1,000
aside for my emergency fund good I made
a couple mistakes about a year ago
I started with one of the settlement
companies nationwide debt reduction
services and Murrell uh yeah so I had
like fifty five thousand dollars in
credit card debt in one year no no this
is over four years of credit cards oh
caught so you were running up credit
card debt in college well I also have
$40,000 in student loans you're running
a credit card net in college cuz you
just said you left and you'd been in San
Francisco for one year yeah yeah exactly
and so I started last year with them in
August and you know obviously I've been
getting you know those letters and stuff
but I finally moved to Sacramento in May
and the debt I accumulate because I left
some credit cards off of the settlement
they accumulated a little bit over San
Francisco and some of them were my
wife's credit cards as well so I just
recently put her on the plan to in June
I'm wondering if maybe it's not too late
to pull that out and not ruin her credit
you know like my credits already been
ruined does hope you know hoping to buy
a house in a couple years I think you
need to stop buying stuff for a while
well I definitely stopped buying stuff
you know I have two new cars that what's
your household income right now I am
making about eighty eight thousand yen
your household income does your wife
work yeah that's that I see going to
school and doing part-time work so she
doesn't make too much when does she
graduated from school I don't know this
year
at the end of the calendar year yeah so
in May grace you don't have our
bachelors in what her associate's
degrees gonna be in what in May oh it's
been a graphic design so she already has
some experience and I feel she just
wanted to get this degree to kind of
help get her a you know higher paying
job you know so how much was she
bringing in right now she's bringing in
about fifteen hundred a month okay I
want her to gear up her side hustle like
triple because a good graphic artist can
do all kinds of side hustle while you're
working on an associate's degree okay
okay so let's get her income up what do
you own your stupid cars so my one car
is twenty thousand the other cars
fifteen thousand and they're both only a
year old so they they don't have they're
not worth what I uh ya know so what do
you what are you 26
I'm 27 year 27 yeah it sounds about
right
I don't know if it's too late for me to
pull her out and it's not listen you're
dancing around the edges of the whole
thing okay the thing you're dealing with
there will answer your question but your
overall problem is is you've got to have
a holistic change in how you view all of
this you can't just go over here and fix
the little side thing while all this
other crap going on okay you have two
cars you can't afford you're not on a
budget and you got spin like you're in
Congress oh you do I definitely do yeah
cuz you have no idea where your money's
going yeah okay so I'm gonna help you I
want you to go through our nine week
class Financial Peace University and I'm
gonna show you how to sell the cars how
to get yourself out of debt and I'm
gonna completely transform your life
you're gonna be a completely different
person one year from now if you do the
stuff I teach you to do and you'll get
your life back sir right now you just
stress
and yes you've got to put it into the
stupid debt settlement thing it doesn't
work they're ripping you off and they
don't do their job and they don't get
you out it's going to look like all of
you filed chapter 13 bankruptcy when
this is done so cancel every bit of that
keep your money
turn your money towards this program
I'll pay for it I don't want your money
I'll help you